La crise au Yémen
est la pire crise humanitaire au monde.
Les besoins en termes d’aide humanitaire
et de protection des civils
n'ont jamais été aussi grands.
J'étais dans ma famille
à Sanaa quand la maison a été bombardée.
Mon fils aîné est décédé.
Environ 17 millions de personnes
sont en situation d'insécurité alimentaire,
ce qui en fait la plus grave
crise alimentaire dans le monde.
Si le monde ne nous aide pas,
le Yémen sera perdu.
Il sera envahi par les catastrophes,
les maladies, les épidémies,
jusqu’à un point de non-retour.
On a une guerre très sale au Yémen.
Il y a pas de contrôle international
sur cette guerre.
Ça aboutit à la terreur,
ça aboutit à la destruction
des hôpitaux, des écoles.
Le système sanitaire
est complètement au point mort.
La situation est vraiment, vraiment,
très, très alarmante ici.
L'Arabie saoudite
contrôle toute entrée dans le Yémen.
C'est un pays qui est cadenassé.
C'est très difficile de s'y rendre,
d'obtenir des visas,
de travailler, d'enquêter.
Et c'est une vraie volonté
d'empêcher que de l'information
sorte de ce pays.
Il y a beaucoup de journalistes
qui ont été tués,
beaucoup de journalistes emprisonnés.
Pour un journaliste occidental,
la mission est quasiment impossible.
C'est un pays dangereux oui,
les journalistes risquent leur peau
quand ils vont là-bas.
C'est évident et...
c'est nécessaire en même temps.
Salut tout le monde,
je suis pour Brut au Yémen.
J'ai réussi à pénétrer dans le pays
le plus inaccessible au monde,
particulièrement pour
les reporters occidentaux.
Et je suis venu pour vous expliquer
comment la guerre impacte
le quotidien des civils
mais aussi pour vous montrer
leurs conditions de vie.
Donc là, on est avec Shamsen,
il a 22 ans, il vivait à Sanaa
et il a été victime
d'une balle perdue.
La balle est rentrée par ici
et elle est ressortie par là.
Donc il s'est retrouvé avec
tout ce côté-là paralysé.
Là, il a une demi-paralysie
et son œil aussi,
il voit plus avec.
On peut dire que c'est un miraculé.
Parce que pour que la balle
ait traversé son cerveau
et qu'il soit encore vivant,
on peut dire que c’était pas son heure.
Sur place, pour aller
à la rencontre des Yéménites
j'ai rejoint un humanitaire français
qui travaille depuis plus de 15 ans
dans des zones de conflit
avec différentes ONG
et qui a l'habitude de
venir en aide aux déplacés.
C'est un garçon,
c’est un petit garçon.
Sa peau commence déjà
à être attaquée, tu vois.
Il commence à avoir des signes
de problèmes de peau.
Il faut savoir que si un enfant est infecté
par des matières fécales,
il peut se déshydrater très, très rapidement
par une gastro-entérite.
En l’espace de même pas 24 heures,
il peut décéder.
Donc le principal problème,
c’est surtout l’eau et l’hygiène pour ces enfants-là.
Ici, la plupart des habitations
sont faites avec des morceaux de bois
ou ce sont des petites tentes.
Et ce qu'il faut bien réaliser,
c'est que ce sont des gens
qui ont fui des zones
de combat où ils avaient
des maisons en dur
dans lesquelles ils habitaient
depuis plusieurs années
voire des dizaines d'années.
Donc ils ont vraiment
tout perdu.
Je vais vous faire visiter une maison
pour que vous puissiez voir les conditions
dans lesquelles vivent la majorité
des personnes déplacées au Yémen.
Il y a pas d’électricité,
il y a pas d’eau, pas de toilettes,
les conditions de vie sont
vraiment très précaires.
Salam Aleykum.
C’est là où les enfants dorment.
Avec la chaleur qu’il fait,
c’est complètement étouffant.
Donc ils peuvent pas rester à l’intérieur,
comme vous le voyez, c’est vide.
Une grande partie des réfugiés vivent
dans des conditions vraiment insupportables.
Ici, c’est la chambre des parents.
Voilà le lit.
Vous pouvez voir l’intimité
et la qualité de l’endroit où ils vivent.
On n'a même pas la place pour se lever.
Il faut savoir qu’il y a plus de
3 millions de Yéménites qui ont été déplacés
et qui vivent dans des conditions
aussi précaires que celles-ci.
Et c’est bien pour cette raison
qu’on dit que la crise au Yémen
est la pire crise humanitaire au monde.
Nous sommes des déplacés de Sanaa.
Nous avons pris la fuite pour venir ici.
[Un jour,] je suis allée au marché mais j’ai laissé
mon fils de 13 ans à la maison
parce qu’il se disputait avec les autres.
Nous étions allés au marché avec mes enfants,
c’était un jour de fête,
un missile a frappé notre maison.
Il était seul à la maison avec un autre enfant.
À notre retour, ils étaient déjà morts.
Ils sont morts le premier jour de la fête.
Pour comprendre
comment ces civils
se sont retrouvés
dans ce camp de déplacés,
il faut que je vous explique la guerre
qui se déroule actuellement au Yémen.
Je vous préviens, c'est pas simple,
faut s'accrocher un peu.
Les causes du conflit yéménite
reviennent à la révolution de 2011,
parce que, comme dans d’autres pays arabes,
il y a eu aussi une révolution en 2011
pour mettre fin à l’autoritarisme
de l’ex-président Ali Abdallah Saleh
qui a gouverné le Yémen de 1978 à fin 2011.
Cet ex-président n’a pas supporté le fait
que son vice-président, Abdrabbo Mansour Hadi,
qui est aujourd’hui
le président au Yémen, lui succède.
Et donc, il s’est allié
à ses anciens ennemis, les Houthis,
pour prendre le pouvoir dès septembre 2014
avec la prise de Sanaa, la capitale du Yémen.
Il y a la guerre au Yémen
parce que les Saoudiens
ont constitué une coalition
avec les Émirats arabes unis
et toute une série de pays arabes sunnites,
face à une rébellion qui est chiite
et soutenue par l’Iran.
Parce que l’Iran, c’est le grand fantasme
des Saoudiens, ils en ont une trouille terrible.
L’Arabie saoudite considère
le Yémen comme son arrière-cour.
Tout ce qui se passe au Yémen,
ça les emmerde.
La situation au Yémen, aujourd’hui,
est très complexe bien sûr,
puisqu’on a au nord un pouvoir rebelle,
le pouvoir des Houthis,
qui tient fermement ces régions du nord.
Et puis, on a un pouvoir légitime qui réside
principalement à Riyad, dans la capitale saoudienne
et qui ne peut exercer ses prérogatives
dans les régions du Yémen qu’il est censé contrôler.
Et puis, on a une autre force politique,
extrêmement puissante,
qui est représentée
par le mouvement séparatiste au sud
qui essaye d’étendre son influence
dans les gouvernorats du sud
avec l’aide des Émirats arabes unis
qui ont soutenu et créé
des milices séparatistes au sud.
L'une des conséquences dramatiques
de cette guerre pour les civils,
c'est une énorme pénurie alimentaire
dans tout le pays
et ça concerne environ
80 % de la population du Yémen.
Pour que vous ayez un aperçu,
un petit peu, de l'urgence alimentaire,
dans ce camp, par exemple,
les enfants que vous avez derrière,
ils mangent exclusivement de ça.
C’est du pain qui est cuit dans de l’huile
et comme vous pouvez le voir,
l’huile, elle est carrément noire.
Une fois que l’huile est frelatée,
bien entendu, les enfants tombent malades
et il y a pas de structures médicales
pour les prendre en charge.
Il y a pas de nutriments suffisants
pour pouvoir participer à la croissance des enfants.
Sur l'ensemble du territoire du Yémen,
la situation alimentaire
est vraiment catastrophique
et il faut vraiment se mobiliser
pour leur apporter un soutien d'urgence.
Là, on a eu de la chance d'arriver au moment
où une ONG est passée en même temps que nous,
elle leur a donné un sac de riz
comme celui-là. Et c'est l'essentiel
de l'aide qu'ils reçoivent.
Ils reçoivent ni légumes, ni viande,
ni quoi que ce soit en général.
C'est simplement du riz.
Ce sac lui permet de nourrir
ses enfants pendant 10 jours.
Mais il y a pas de cycle
de distribution régulier
donc c'est vraiment très, très, très aléatoire.
Je vais rentrer dans
un hôpital pédiatrique de Marib
pour vous montrer
comment la pénurie alimentaire
et les blocus sur la nourriture
impactent les enfants.
Donc là, je suis avec la petite Rama
qui a seulement sept mois.
Elle pesait moins de 4 kilos
quand elle est arrivée dans l'hôpital
alors qu'elle devrait en faire au moins 7.
Elle souffre de malnutrition
et c'est parce qu'elle arrive de Sanaa,
la capitale du Yémen
qui est sous contrôle houthi
où le prix des denrées alimentaires
est très élevé.
Les médecins lui donnent
du lait thérapeutique
et ses jours ne sont
pas en danger.
Comme vous le voyez,
elle va beaucoup mieux.
Je les remercie.
Nous sommes des êtres
humains qui subissons ces guerres.
Ces conflits nous ont été imposés.
J’espère que ma famille
et tout enfant souffrant
pourront retrouver la santé.
La guerre a entraîné
l'effondrement économique du pays.
Le prix des denrées alimentaires
a augmenté de 150 %,
celui du carburant, de près de 200 %
et cette explosion des prix
a eu un impact très négatif
dans le domaine des transports,
de la santé, sur l'agriculture
mais aussi sur
l'électricité et l'eau.
En dehors de la question de la nourriture,
il y a aussi le problème de l'eau.
Vous pouvez voir que là, ils emmagasinent
des bidons mais ça, c'est de l'eau salée
qui sort d'un puits qui est
à peu près à 2 kilomètres d'ici.
Donc c'est les enfants principalement
qui vont la chercher et qui viennent
avec des bidons sous le soleil.
Et pour ce qui est de l'eau potable,
c'est une demi-journée de marche.
Les enfants font une demi-journée de marche
pour aller chercher de l'eau potable
et revenir.
Donc vous pouvez voir qu'à tous les niveaux,
il y a vraiment tout à faire.
En 2019, l'ONU estime
que 16 millions de Yéménites
n'ont pas accès à l'eau potable. Cette situation
a entraîné une terrible épidémie de choléra
et depuis début 2016, au moins 2900 personnes
sont mortes à cause de la maladie.
Et, dans le pays, 1,1 million de personnes
ont été infectées par le choléra.
Ce qui m'a particulièrement touché
dans la situation de ces 3 millions de déplacés,
c'est le sort des enfants.
Pour la plupart, ils n'ont pas école
et ne font pas grand-chose de leurs journées.
Il y a plus de 3500 enfants
qui ont besoin d'éducation
et il y a seulement
400 places disponibles.
Et les écoles, c'est ce que
vous voyez derrière moi.
C’est de simples tentes
avec quelques tables et quelques chaises.
C'est très important que, malgré la guerre,
on puisse maintenir un système éducatif
parce que c'est justement par l'éducation
que la population
va pouvoir reprendre le dessus.
C'est ce qui va permettre
aux enfants de voir d'autres horizons.
Et notamment de sortir de ce cycle de violence,
qu’ils s’engagent pas dans les milices
ou dans les différentes factions
qui sont actuellement en guerre.
Donc pouvoir leur donner des perspectives
d'avenir autres que combattre,
tuer et mourir pour des raisons
qu'ils ignorent eux-mêmes.
Tu joues au foot ?
Comment, tu ne joues pas au foot ?
Avec les pieds seulement.
Ah oui, vous jouez au ballon ?
C’est magnifique, c’est super.
Qui est le meilleur joueur parmi vous ?
Nous tous.
Nous avons quitté notre région
pour venir ici à cause de la guerre.
De la guerre...
J’espère que vous pourrez y retourner
dans de meilleures conditions qu’avant.
Mais il faut réussir à l’école pour pouvoir
tout reconstruire d'accord ?
Oui.
Que veux-tu faire quand tu seras grand ?
Je voudrais être médecin.
Médecin !
Si Dieu le veut.
Tu ramassais de l’herbe
pour nourrir les moutons
et tu as été blessé
par l'explosion d'une mine ?
Où est-ce que tu as été blessé,
montre-moi ?
Tu vois comment ta jambe a été blessée ?
Il faut être prudent
quand vous voyez des mines.
Mais grâce à Dieu, tu t’en es bien tiré.
Tu as eu de la chance
parce que ta blessure est très légère,
sinon tu aurais pu perdre ta jambe
ou ta mobilité.
Nous sommes malheureusement dans l’incapacité
de secourir tous les civils et enfants
et ce, à cause
de la forte présence des mines,
toute cette région est pleine de mines.
Ces mines ont été posées
pour entraver le déplacement des civils.
Que ce soit sur le chemin pour aller au travail
ou pour toute autre activité en dehors du camp,
ou en recueillant de la nourriture des fermes
dans les alentours.
Il faut renforcer les opérations de déminage
pour pouvoir préserver la vie
de cette nouvelle génération,
si Dieu le veut.
La guerre au Yémen, ça nous concerne
nous aussi, les Français.
La France
vend des armes à des pays
qui font la guerre sur place :
l’Arabie saoudite
et les Émirats arabes unis.
Pourtant, le président de la République
et le gouvernement ont toujours nié
que du matériel de guerre français
ait pu être utilisé dans le conflit au Yémen.
Nous sommes complètement fidèles
dans les ventes d'armes,
au Traité du commerce des armes
que nous respectons totalement.
Nous respectons aussi la procédure
européenne qui nécessite
des contrôles nécessaires.
Mais en ce qui concerne
la guerre du Yémen,
l'action de l'Arabie saoudite
s'effectue essentiellement par voie aérienne
et nous ne fournissons rien
à l'armée de l'air saoudienne.
Je n'ai pas connaissance
du fait que des armes
soient utilisées
directement dans ce conflit.
Il y a un certain
nombre d'armes qui...
Vous ne savez pas ou vous
ne voulez pas nous le dire ?
À ma connaissance...
Vous voyez que vous êtes agacée.
À ma connaissance, c'est que
je n'ai pas connaissance.
Les mots ont un sens.
La France a une politique
extrêmement rigoureuse en la matière
avec une commission interministérielle,
justement, de contrôle des armements
qui est présidée par le Premier ministre
et qui est justement très scrupuleuse sur ce point.
Et nous ne faisons
pas partie des fournisseurs
sur ces matières-là,
de l'Arabie saoudite
sur justement ce conflit.
Sauf que depuis,
le média en ligne Disclose
a révélé un document confidentiel
remis au président de la République
et aux principaux membres
du gouvernement le 3 octobre 2018.
Donc avant les déclarations
qu’on vient d’entendre.
Et cette note classée secret défense
prouve qu’une partie de l’armement français
est bien utilisée
dans la guerre au Yémen.
Il y a donc de fortes probabilités pour
que des armes françaises aient servi
à tuer des civils.
C’est un scandale d’État
parce que ces documents classés
"confidentiel-défense" dévoilaient
les mensonges du gouvernement français.
Ce qui est scandaleux,
c’est qu’un président de la République
mente aussi effrontément.
Ils avaient connaissance
que les armes françaises
étaient utilisées au Yémen
contre des civils.
On a vraiment un gouvernement
qui couvre une guerre sale au Yémen.
La France, finalement,
a du mal à reconnaître
que ces armes qui sont
vendues en Arabie saoudite
ou aux Émirats sont utilisées
au Yémen de manière offensive.
Évidemment, elles peuvent
être utilisées pour tuer des civils
du fait de bombardements indiscriminés.
La France est mêlée
à une guerre inadmissible.
Les Saoudiens et les Émirats arabes unis
sont bien incapables de mener cette guerre
s’il n’y a pas le renseignement américain,
le renseignement français
et le matériel américain
et le matériel français.
C’est une cobelligérance, c’est-à-dire
la forme la plus grave de guerre
pratiquée par intermédiaire.
Moralement, politiquement,
c’est indéfendable.
Pour avoir révélé cette note
classée secret défense,
les journalistes de Disclose
ont été convoqués
par les services
de renseignement français.
On a été auditionnés
par la DGSI.
C'est un service de
renseignement intérieur
qui s'occupe généralement
des affaires de terrorisme.
On est sous enquête
pour avoir compromis
le secret de la défense nationale.
Ça veut dire qu'on aurait
porté atteinte aux intérêts
supérieurs de la nation
en dévoilant ces informations
d'intérêt public.
Donc on utilise
le secret défense
pour poursuivre
les journalistes.
Si, à chaque fois,
il y a une convocation,
non mais on rêve, non ?
Le confidentiel défense
n'a pas à être respecté.
C'est une façon
de cacher les choses.
On met le cachet
confidentiel défense,
comme ça, on répond pas.
Aujourd’hui, le gouvernement
français, l'État français, estime
que le commerce des armes avec
l’Arabie saoudite est plus important
que les vies de milliers
de civils au Yémen.
Il y a très peu d'informations
qui sortent du Yémen,
c'est donc très difficile d'avoir
un bilan exact du nombre
de morts et de blessés.
Et là, je suis devant
un ancien centre de formation
qui a été réquisitionné
par les autorités pour devenir
un hôpital de campagne
où il y a des centaines de blessés,
qui sont soit amputés,
soit dans un état
végétatif, dans le coma
parce qu’ils ont été blessés au front.
Il y a certains blessés qui dorment
parfois entre deux lits,
pour vous dire à quel point
il y a très peu d’espace ici
et à quel point ils sont en surnombre.
Pareil, dans cette pièce,
elle doit faire à peine 8 mètres carrés
et il y a 5 patients
qui dorment et qui vivent ici.
La plupart ont été blessés
par des éclats d'obus,
des balles ou des mines.
Il y a pas de lits médicalisés,
il y a pas de matériel orthopédique.
Un grand manque de personnel.
Un grand manque d'hygiène.
C'est-à-dire des risques d’infection.
Donc, vraiment, la situation
est vraiment, vraiment, très, très alarmante ici.
Il nous manque certaines choses,
comme des prothèses.
La qualité des prothèses
en silicone n'est pas bonne.
Elles se dégradent rapidement.
Certaines personnes
sont amputées de plusieurs membres.
Le silicone dont nous disposons en ce moment
n’est pas du silicone médical,
ce qui a entraîné des réactions et des maladies.
Vous pouvez voir l'état
du matériel et c'est représentatif
de tout le reste.
Ce fauteuil-là
n'est plus utilisable.
La plupart en fait,
ils sont abîmés à ce niveau-là,
au niveau des roues,
c'est pas du tout fonctionnel.
Et il y a des salles
remplies de matériel cassé.
Ils ont aucunes réserves
et il y a plus de 800 personnes
amputées ou dans
l'incapacité de se déplacer.
De personnes en situation
de handicap très lourd.
Le système sanitaire est
complètement au point mort.
Donc si ce n'est pas
par l'aide humanitaire,
ces gens-là ne recevront
aucune aide.
Ce conflit, il n’a plus aucun sens en fait.
Il est difficile aujourd'hui d'être optimiste
puisque l'on voit que
l'unité yéménite est menacée.
L'état de belligérance continue toujours
au détriment, évidemment,
de la population civile
qui souffre de plus en plus.
Et on n'a pas l'esquisse
d'une solution qui émerge.
Ce qui est important aujourd'hui,
c'est de véhiculer cette information,
de la partager,
de partager le plus possible
l'information qui tourne
autour du Yémen.
Il faut que la question des ventes d'armes
au Yémen continue
d'être au cœur de l'actualité
pour qu’on puisse exercer
notre rôle de citoyen, de contre-pouvoir.
Le Yémen, pire catastrophe humanitaire
au monde, ça commence à toucher
la société civile en France.
En mai dernier, des dockers
du port du Havre,
soutenus par des ONG,
ont refusé d'accueillir
un navire qui devait charger
des armes, à destination
des pays du Golfe,
justement pour éviter
qu'elles tuent des civils yéménites.
Il faudrait que…
on passe à un stade supérieur.
C'est-à-dire à un moment donné
qu'il y ait des
manifestations publiques.
Parce que moi, j'ai connu
les manifestations contre la guerre d'Algérie,
contre la guerre d'Indochine,
contre la guerre du Vietnam.
Et depuis, plus rien.
Je demande à tous ceux qui
vont entendre mon message.
Je vous demande d'avoir
de la compassion pour le Yémen,
de la miséricorde,
pour qu'on puisse réformer
et reconstruire notre pays,
notre patrie,
pour qu’on puisse vivre
en toute liberté et dignité.
Humainement, nous voulons
vivre comme le reste du monde.
CO₂      m³      km²
non, vraiment.
aucune...
rien.
Lorem ipsum dolor sit amet,
consectetur adipiscing elit.
À Sanaa, là-bas
j’étais à l’université
En première année.
Nous avons été pris par l’arrivée
des milices des Houthis
aux gouvernorats
de Amran et de Sanaa.
À leur arrivée à Sanaa, nous avons été
fortement affectés par la guerre,
tant au niveau économique
qu’au niveau psychologique.
Les études ont été suspendues.
Nous ne trouvions
plus de quoi manger.
Il suffisait de sortir de
chez soi pour être interrogé :
"Où est-ce qu’on allait,
pour quelles raisons, etc?"
À ce moment-là, la situation
est devenue invivable
pour toute personne libre qui
refuse de vivre comme l’esclave d’autrui.
Nous sommes nés libres
et vivront libres quoi qu’il advienne.
Nous avons demandé la liberté,
pas un état de violation
mais un état de démocratie,
avec des élections,
comme nous vivions auparavant sous
la république yéménite.
Ils ont détenu les personnes qui les défiaient
et les ont emprisonnés et torturés.
Nous avons vu ce qu’ils ont fait aux autres
et avons compris que notre tour viendrait.
Quand je me suis senti visé,
j’ai été obligé de fuir avec ma famille
pour venir ici où nous sommes en sécurité.
Si nous étions restés,
ils nous auraient séparés.
Ils séparaient les frères,
les pères de leurs enfants,
les hommes de leurs femmes.
Ils ont même commis des violences
à l’égard des femmes et des enfants.
Nous étions obligés de fuir la guerre.
Dans notre économie sous
la république yéménite,
les pauvres s’appauvrissent
et les riches s’enrichissent,
la classe moyenne quant à elle,
elle s’appauvrit aussi.